[Music]
how was your daughter because I remember
I ran into you recently and your
daughter was in she's adorable yeah she
she's three years old now she is so
awesome and she's smart and adorable but
what I what I found out though I found
out the hard way you have to be very
careful what you let your kids watch on
in terms of TV and movies and I wasn't
really I thought I was doing okay like
showing her you know kiddie stuff but we
were driving around one day doing
daddy-daughter stuff and having a great
time we go to this Starbucks near where
I live and it's like the nicest
employees at the Starbucks and the
absolute worst customers it's all these
little tweeting tumbling facebooking
basically douche bags I'm sorry but
that's just who's there so they're all
just sitting there like me and so I go
in there man that noise and yeah I think
that gets you a stronger signal if you
just so who's in it yeah
oh nice I get a question she gets a
cusan I get like a coffee we're sitting
down were heaven she's making jokes and
I'm laughing my head off what I don't
see who sits next to me this old old old
bald black guy with a bright white beard
sits next to me I don't see him until my
daughter stands up in her chair and
points at him and goes daddy a monkey
monkey much she's screaming monkey at
this guy now first off she's doing it in
the absolute worst place she can be
doing this because we're surrounded by
like hashtag races baby
everywhere yeah so then what so how do I
handle this did I do the mature dad
thing you'll sweetie that is not what we
that is extremely offensive we don't
know here it was my solution I pick her
up
I put her face close to mine and I run
out of the Starbucks and I just go back
exactly I just know I just yell over her
adorable racism like that's my only
solution cat just counter it java yeah
make noise and then what I realize is if
somebody were sitting far away from me
in the Starbucks
all they would have seen is me and my
daughter and then an old black Isis and
I just go back I got like it still just
looks horribly racist there you know so
then I'm driving home and I'm shaking
like the hell was that
like which where did she look at that so
um we get home and my wife's like well
you've had her all morning I'll give you
a break you know so I'm in the kitchen
like still oh my god like recovering and
I hear them talking and uh so my wife
goes what do you want to do sweetie and
my daughter says I want to watch a movie
so he goes oh what movie do you want to
watch and I hear my daughter go up I
want to watch Lion King which Lion King
is a great movie it is about an adorable
lion cub who is orphaned and then exiled
and meets all sorts of helpful wonderful
friends including this old bald monkey
with a bright white beard so she just
thought she had seen her friend it look
I'm not saying Lion King is racist I
just
I'm just saying it needs to come with a
warning sticker morning three years and
younger may cause race riots
oh please on the DVD that's all I'm
asking